remember the iPad pro that giant tablet
that Apple launched last fall that was
just huge and designed to be a computer
and everything for everybody well this
is also the iPad pro it's nine point
seven inches it's a lot more portable it
weighs about a pound it's super thin and
light but it has all the same features
as the bigger iPad pro you can use the
Apple pencil to draw and doodle you can
use the keyboard to get real work done
it's super fast at at the AMEX processor
it has all of the same camera stuff all
the same software everything is just a
smaller package here the two new things
it has going for it are all in the
display one is called night shift which
lets you change the display in it as the
day goes on so that your eyes are still
be comfortable and you won't stay up
because of Blues which is terrible for
when you're reading in bed the other is
called true tone and it will actually
adapt to the light of the room here in
to make sure that you have an accurate
display no matter what you're doing it's
kind of weird when you toggle it on and
off but it really seems to help
basically this is sort of a catch-all
device it's designed for people who have
an iPad but haven't upgraded it in years
it's designed for people who are using
Windows PCs that they'd like to upgrade
it's designed for everybody it's 599
dollars with 32 gigs of storage or 749
with 128 gigs or $899 for 256 gigs of
storage which is crazy basically this is
meant for the iPad for absolutely